in the ten years since it was unveiled
berlin's holocaust memorial has become a
powerful draw for visitors and residents
alike a broad expanse that invites
reflection and a favorite background for
photos in all a showcase for Germany's
effort to come to terms with its Nazi
past but for the topic comes up a lot
among friends we discuss it and the
responsibility that we all carry for him
reminders of that responsibility dot the
German capital in the mid-1960s this
sign was erected near Berlin's landmark
Khedive a department store it's a
reminder of the places of horror the
concentration and death camps of the
Third Reich at the time the placard was
highly controversial many Germans at the
time wanted to forget the Holocaust and
the Nazi dictatorship what is these days
it is still an irritation people always
make the same argument at some point we
have to put that period behind us know
in I say it is not passed for x so the
sign remains conjuring up different
emotions among those who take notice
finally already from it mentions the
teacher I went with my students to
Dachau we are still trying to deal with
that era even today to submit of course
I have sympathy for the victims but I
don't feel as if I'm responsible person
leak minus the atrocities have been such
a burden throughout my life so velocity
Aden is at some point we have to put an
end to it Jurgen van zdenka Asotasi
lucidum it
trains leading to life trains leading to
death a sculpture at one of Berlin's
main commuter stations one side portrays
the estimated ten thousand Jewish
children who were evacuated to Britain
and saved the other side the one and a
half million children who died in the
camps you might not love nothing most
people just walk right past on their
daily commute but if someone has
traveled a long way and is interested in
the city those are the ones who will
have a closer look at it right in the
dark woods as with these simple sidewalk
markers many Berlin students have
researched the former addresses of
Holocaust victims in their city the
plaque commemorating this Jewish couple
bears the names of modulator and Gustav
Lefevre who died in Auschwitz shyamala
authenticity this place where I'm
standing is no normal place it has a
unique history a meaning people should
take the time to reflect not just walk
away mclovin the students say their
efforts will be worth it if just a few
people come across these stones and are
moved to contemplate and to remember